wake the [ __ ] up Americans I'm here to
talk some sense into you well hold on a
second I'm Canadian
and when I say Americans I'm including
Canadians in that because Canadians
admit it we're really just the 51st
state we're like California with igloos
so Canadians Americans same thing anyway
what was I saying
wake the Gulf Americans I'm here to talk
some sense into you as a nation we suck
with languages 43% of all people around
the world are bilingual that includes
over 50 percent of the people in Europe
and in some countries like Indonesia and
Philippines virtually everybody is
bilingual and it's very common in a lot
of countries for people to speak three
four or even five languages on a regular
basis but in America only 20% of the
people are bilingual and guess what
almost all of those people are
immigrants or the children of immigrants
amongst homegrown Americans very few are
bilingual and in the northern province
of Canada the situation is not much
different most of the people who are
bilingual are immigrants or francophone
Canadians french-speaking Canadians
Anglophone Canadians are generally
monolingual very few of them are
bilingual in Australia the numbers are
even worse and in Europe guess which
countries have the lowest levels of
bilingualism
so the point I'm making is that
Anglophones basically do not become
bilingual I don't want to say that
Anglophones are lazy but why the hell
are we so damn lazy well obviously it's
because of a lack of incentive English
is the international language so why
should I put in all this time and effort
to speak another language when other
people will just speak English with me
isn't it kind of sort of arrogant to
expect all the other people to put in
all the effort to accommodate us
anybody who has travelled has probably
seen Americans or other Anglophones
getting frustrated with the locals when
they couldn't speak English but if those
Anglophones had ever learned a second
language for themselves maybe they would
be able to understand and empathize with
that other person and find a way to
communicate with them the truth is
English is not spoken by most people in
the world despite the fact that it's the
de facto international language most
people simply don't speak English unless
you stick to the main tourist traps and
who likes cheesy tourist traps knowing
another major language can greatly help
you communicate around the world there's
also no guarantee that English will be
the International language for much
longer not too long ago the
international language was French and in
the future maybe it will be Chinese or
Spanish who knows well it probably won't
be Chinese but you never know the number
of Spanish speakers is growing rapidly
and a lot of spanish-speaking countries
are in the process of developing rapidly
so Spanish could become much more
important in the near future but even if
Spanish never becomes the de facto
international language there's no
denying that knowing Spanish would be
incredibly useful in a lot of places
around the world
but even if there were no practical
benefits to learning a second language
learning another language simply makes
you smarter do you want to be stupid
learning a second language actually
makes your brain grow it increases your
memory it increases your attention span
it helps you deal with ambiguities and
nuance in meaning it makes you better at
multitasking and adapting to new
circumstances and learning a second
language helps offset the beginning of
dementia by years up to five years in
fact learning a language is brain
exercise learning a language also helps
you in less tangible ways it helps you
understand different ways of seeing
reality look at this color right here
what color is this if you're an English
speaker you probably thought that's blue
now have a look at this color right here
what color is that if you're an English
speaker you might be thinking well
that's a shade of blue that's light blue
but if you are Japanese then you
probably thought this is a different
color that's not blue it's actually
water color in Japanese these are two
different colors people perceive them as
different colors because they have two
different names for these colors but
wait that doesn't make sense they're
just two shades of the same color I
don't understand oh really okay well how
about this color right here would you
say that's red okay how about this color
right here if you're an English speaker
you probably said that's pink but there
are a lot of languages in the world that
do not see this as pink they see this as
a shade of red the same way that you see
light blue as a shade of blue
these ways of perceiving reality are the
core of what we call culture by
understanding different ways of
perceiving reality we are understanding
cultural variation and cultural
difference that greater cultural
understanding can bring people together
and create greater international
relationships and can maybe even prevent
Wars how many wars have broken out
because the two sides couldn't
comprehend each other's way of
perceiving the situation I can only
imagine
so Anglophones stopped being the
laughingstock of the world and stop
selling yourself short start learning a
foreign language and expand your mind
this is Paul thank you for watching the
Lang focus channel leave your comments
down below talk to you later have a good
night
[Music]
you
[Music]